[Music]
let's go out to
Detroit man home of the lions that are
just crushing it right now let's talk to
Kayla what's up
Kayla hey how are you good how are
you nervous don't be nervous you're good
you're in good hands what's
up um so I guess my main question was
that I've recent ly become an alcoholic
and I'm not quite
sure how it happen or why I
guess I don't know that that's the most
important thing right now no it's not
but
um I know I need to deal with it and I'm
also working on that too what does that
mean um I'm just started recently going
to therapy um I gave my husband all my
cards and stuff so that way I don't have
access to buy
it are you spinning well back back me up
here what happened how how I mean how
did we get
here
um well I
guess it's only been really like strong
for the last six months um but it kind
of I think it started when we moved out
here uh my husband kind of went through
a deep depression phase and I kind of
had to pick up the slck of everything in
the house and it kind of just became
overwhelming and after a year of doing
that I slowly started drinking
to make myself feel better and it just
got worse and worse and worse over time
okay um so in your case alcohol works
man because your home life sucked was
really
tough yeah
and I know it's not like PC to say but
being married to somebody who's in a
dark depression and can't get out of bed
and you're taking care of everything do
you have
kids yes we do okay so you're doing
everything everything everything plus
worried about the electric bill plus
worried about things that y'all had not
previously agreed were your part of your
job description
right do you have a history of
alcoholism in your
family um unfortunately yes one of my uh
sister s has died from it my mother has
died from it and died was an alcoh
alcoholic
yes so you are playing with
fire yes
yeah and then like I I know that and I
don't want to do it but it's just like
there's something in me that I just
can't like I know I get past it's a it's
a demon I
know I promise there's light on the
other side but right now it is scary
scary
scary it is because you told yourself
this would never happened to you after
walking with your sister's death your
mom's death you you swore up and down
and the challenge here is yes you're
drinking and yes you're scared to death
and yes it's like becoming easier and
easier have you had a drink
today no not not yet okay but right when
you get off this call you will to calm
down because you're nervous
right I'm still going to love you I'm
not gonna be mad at
you yes okay
um not only is that the case but you
swore to yourself it would never happen
to you and so you've lost trust in
Kayla is that
fair
absolutely so I think we can get to the
why it sounds like your childhood was
hell on Earth
Fair
yes um
and then your
body for lack of better terms you've
married your unfinished business and you
married somebody with some similar
mental health challenges and you're
going to solve it and suddenly you
realize I can't solve this and your body
was like ah I got a plan for when we
can't solve a
problem both genetic bad and
behaviorally right you're in it you're
in it up to your eyeballs
yes there's one plan and one plan only
you got to go scorched
Earth because you're GNA
die if I'm you if you're my sister if
you my wife if you were one of my
closest closest
friends I would tell you I don't see a
path forward without you going to an
impatient treatment right now before
this thing gets the train completely
leaves the
station the fact that you haven't drank
this morning before this call that's a
good I'm taking that as a good sign
because you're nervous up until now
right
yes did you drink last night so you
could sleep before
today yes I did
yeah so it's it's it's growing on you
like a dementor right like a shadow
coming up behind
you yeah it is how's your husband right
now can he handle things for for a a for
a a few
weeks uh he absolutely could um he has
tried to getting me to do impatient
treatment what's your
hesitancy uh I I have very bad anxiety
with not being around my kids okay I
know that he could take care of them I
just leaving them for that amount of
time it's just stresses me out and then
have you heard me talk about
anxiety yes all the
time have you taken that anxiety
test yes and I got red on every every
spot every one of them every single one
all right what's my cornerstone rule
about
anxiety which oh you're gonna have
to do what oh was you're just gonna have
to tell me okay my cornerstone rule or
I'll say I'll I'll I'll say it in nerd
speak okay when you feel anxious about a
thing and you walk away from that
anxiety meaning I know that if I don't
go to impatient Rehabilitation I am
going to die and my kids will experience
what I experienced when my mom
died the guilt the pain the
hell but your body feels anxious about
leaving your kids because in some ways
you're worried about your husband's
ability to care for them and in some
ways they've become a pacifier to you
they're a Xanax for
you they're one glimpse of light in a
pretty dark World
Fair yes yes so it's less about are they
going to be okay and it's more about are
you going to be
okay and when you feel that anxiety you
run and you hug those kids and here's
what happens your body actually
reinforces the anxiety it makes it
stronger because it got what it wanted
it
worked and what it wants is for you not
to get any further away from the light
as possible and those two little kids
are all the light you
got and my cornerstone Rule and it's not
my rule it's Neuroscience the only way
to get those that anxiety to stop is to
head directly into
it you're anxious about leaving your
kids for 30 days I'm gonna Sprint
towards that you anxious about um
how your husband's going to be able to
handle it we're going to sit down and
we're going to make a plan are you
anxious about waking up dead like your
mom like your sister like your
aunt I'm going to make a committed plan
that that never happens to me you see
what I mean this is changing your
posture this is you standing up tall for
the first time in your life and putting
your chin up and your shoulders back and
saying I'm heading right into this and
then you realize I can't walk into this
by myself it's too scary I've been there
I
know and you've got a husband who's
saying hey will you go get this taken
care of cuz I don't want to bury
you you got two little kids looking at
you you've got the ghosts of your mom
saying honey take care of this take care
of this take care of
this how does that all
sound besides really really
scary
um I don't even know it's just SC
that's just scary it is
um and I know I need to do it
okay let this be the
day and
listen your body's going to Crave this
one thing if you've heard me talk about
anything read anything I've written I
always I'm talking about homeostasis
your body's going to want to go back to
what it
knows it knows alcohol it knows chaos it
knows
anxiousness it knows somebody who said
he was going to love you ends up in a
really dark place what your body knows
and so rehab for you hey it's going to
be not drinking right but bigger than
that it's going to be you learning a new
way to
live and that sounds scary but doesn't
that sound freaking
amazing it does it does
imagine walking in your front
door and you just start laughing when
you get home and your knucklehead kids
come running up to you and your
husband's on the couch and you're like
oh
God but the heat is
on and your husband's hung up Christmas
lights somewhere in the house and who
knows whatever whatever fantasy you have
in your
head on you know you can build
that you can't do any of it if you're
drinking
is it unfair that you got this deck of
cards yeah it is I didn't get that deck
of
cards I eat when I'm stressed I don't
drink but that's the card you got and
that's the card you got to deal
with will you make that call
today yes do you promise I do okay I'm
going to have Kelly put a note on the
calendar in 30 days we're going to reach
back out to
you okay
okay this is going to
be absolute hell okay anyone who tells
you otherwise is lying to you
and the light and peace on the other
side of this thing is going to be
something you have never experienced
before in your life and you have an
entire country of people behind you on
this one but by the way we don't matter
the person who matters is your husband
people who matter your kids person that
matters is the woman standing in the
mirror so proud of you Kayla tonight
after you make that call and say I'm
ready to go actually first tell your
husband then tell U make the call and I
want you to shoot us an email and just
say hey I'm checking in tomorrow morning
at whatever time at whatever location
whatever impatient treatment we'll send
you something nice over there I'm really
really proud of you
Kayla today is the first day of the rest
of your
life
man I'm proud of
you